hi I'm marshmallow and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
[Music]
it's actually me Twitter
how does marshmallow DJ if you don't use
headphones thinking face emoji thinking
face emoji thinking face emoji I use in
ear monitors they're kind of like earbud
headphones they fit perfectly to my ear
I can hear everything
skank says doesn't marshmallow get hot
constantly wearing that bloody mask on
your head while DJing it definitely gets
hot but I'm a marshmallow it's all good
again Shakalaka will you bring back Mel
a gang Appreciation Fridays smiley
emoticon yes I 100% will be bringing
those back definitely
so can post Malone and marshmallow music
make a song so I can call you
marshmallow alone that sounds fantastic
and I will get on it ASAP
I left post Malone I think he's super
super talented he's one of my favorite
artists here comes the drama marshmallow
music what do I have to do to play a
game of fortnight with you add me on
epic games
it's me marshmallow and we'll play a few
games maybe get ninja and you can also
follow my twitch account marshmallow
music it'll be a fun time how long did
it take you to make alone took me about
four hours you know I moved away from
home and I wrote the song and it was
exactly how I was feeling and it just
came organically digitized how do I
dance like marshmallow you have to be
alone in your room in front of a mirror
for 10 hours a day and you have to eat
sleep dance get alert submit it would
you guys like to see a GE z slash
marshmallow collab I think it would be
sick in my opinion that actually exists
my song reversed with vic mensa
came out about a month ago so check it
out what car is marshmallow driving I'm
driving the mellow mobile only one
exists and nobody knows what it looks
like super secret top secret stuff
[Music]
Quora what software does marshmallow use
I use Ableton Ableton 10 I started on
GarageBand a lot of people moved to
logic in their early days but I went
right to Ableton and it just worked out
that's all I've used posted what is the
music genre of marshmallow it's been
called future bounce so I'd have to
agree super future bass is another genre
that influences it what are some
interesting facts about marshmallow ie
keep it mellow well I was born in a
grocery store and the rest is history
so I'm marshmallow I came from your
local Safeway let's do some more get it
who made the vocals in marshmallow alone
that was me
it's my voice and I pitched it up and
there you go alone was made Instagram
graceful dot pom-pom dot pet says I
wonder if there will be a day when
marshmallow sings a full-on lyric in one
of his songs smiley emoji there 100%
will be that day waiting on the right
song but look out for it it will just
come naturally and organically you never
wanted to force anything it's actually
me what do you do when your head gets
itchy Wikipedia marshmallow officially
released a collaboration with deceased
rapper lil peep titled spotlight
marshmallow initially had no plans to
release the single until he spoke with
peeps mother who requested as much of
her son's unpublished music be released
as possible 100% true his mom called me
and said my son's music needs to come
out and I obviously obviously accepted
and spotlight was released
I'm so proud and so honored to have been
able to do that song with him 100% more
Twitter why is there not a marshmallow
emoji well Twitter world there's one
coming it's in the works
I can't tell you but it's coming so
watch out is it bad that when I overhear
someone talking about marshmallow I
automatically think of marshmallow music
first the secret plan is working so yes
there's a reason for that there you go
YouTube
[Music]
who else thought marshmallow and logic
would make a cool comedy movie I am 100%
down to do that so logic if you're
watching let's get on it
well hopefully you guys learn something
about me hopefully I answered enough
questions so keep watching and I'll see
you next time
[Music]